this is the best of all stars 2017 team
fights solo kills and 1v1 s next time
you jump into a game of League check out
the scores eSports builds calculator at
the score eSports builds calm
[Music]
it's barren - the Chinese is interrupted
she hid points like sneaky where is the
pentakill mad first blood for Southeast
Asia they're on the board again a flash
head spot in the by Kyung uh trade kill
Lin is now what the call is it the Baron
to keep TP got cancelled it didn't be
the comic bounces out
good since back season he Snipes one got
a final shot debatable the AoE is gonna
help out that tax Aldrin and it will
force turkey away from the Baron how is
that all maybe a little more ambitious
as well and for the term frozen very
very low goes down himself Stone Age one
last shot banker gets the double kill
and gets himself out of turret range
along with ambition I mean no joke one
of the hottest things for la oficina de
village is that cool active oh yeah but
woe comes ml XG doesn't get in sword
aren't taking a bunch of damage but is
he it looks like he's healing under the
pressure LMS is absolutely crushing the
LPL health bars right now as they make
their way into the fight nine five seven
on the backline trying to deliver as he
has to stay in long range mode going off
the Baron that he reset didn't even
reset the image down to four thousand
you have actually going there again
threatening makeup looking joke they
just need to keep my stance a bit
they're going with a bull
the L says and a big hill forward that's
well worth it came through usually the
Shan to stand there for like a half
second realizing and finally completely
it was just across two people
immediately they're taking a half out
fights though I mean yeah they are and
there's also something we talked about a
champs and I get a lot of champions on
the side of LDLs I can really get out on
them
and okie from a job and it says you've
thrown a flash and in this case yeah
love the punches were down even before
the fight started so grading gauge from
LMS break whoa I'm Picasso it was
actually back to away at first
damnit a long way away he you wanted to
change this went down
so ed look at the jump right back in yet
again at Django's is gonna be falling
first so ed snagging a tumble deal for
faker Bray opens up looking for even
more a double kill from BOE now Oh sighs
us pray with best night know what this
has to puff to heal together go ahead
something a matter like hey we're gonna
die okay alright go root gets away
bullet time comes out who's he gonna be
eating a lot of damage from that one
stand in it but not quite dead just get
make it rain
there's the one thing though I don't
know he goes down franksen she's gonna
get tagged 5/7 looking old fake a photo
dump but he gets away
now ruin it up stuff gonna land in from
that dad those fake-ass still post 9 5 7
you know if we gonna let it rip making
it a tinkly hat crewmate over the grapes
like dreaming is boardmaker
planet item open the other patterns here
we started by perusing let it go with
the fall in time so much damages break
so Laura Baker still in spent Dube he's
left out to dry
well you're not gonna find it though no
one day Chuck it's time to go make
yourself a cup and that might be enough
my plan Luzi take that girl I'm brain
thing again bad girl everyone's gonna go
down here Gary died on the Korean side
and that should be it roommate we can
afford that's today so late into this
game means so what these lungs death
time is right
someone needs these minutes they can do
it that's gonna carry
everybody's dead and the game goes
Victoria look at this damn attempt with
Pete not yet I was down to one half HP
and they're gonna have a little bit more
coming in the nignog bring some
teammates none of the CC landing the
troop shoes are in but doesn't matter
[Music]
Flutie gone behind us cause does not
have a way out spies a little bit of
time and he's not gonna bring much here
comes the team the plasma ball first
blood gang coat the first blood King is
here already and backs away and a punish
this summoner spell is fake that Mako
flash earlier from the gang we got the
flat Oh nicely done my young a little
bit more Patrick's now maybe in some
trouble Emperor's divide comes down ml
XG also going to be souping in it's two
versus two one more snack will make a
stunt on to Patrick the damage comes
through the soldiers are there GA now RI
and the damage and Levi turns it around
the nine five seven will now move in
Megan are in the law double kill for him
as Braga gin self son de Mayo with Isaac
remind the shield red for Gil four nine
five seven pink oh so far so good that
poke booty again not getting out has a
big hit
a hit sword aren't trying to walk
through the box Evie but that maybe the
box the people down only switchdriver up
[ __ ] hitting its target who's all right
then oh he played him back so they may
not want it completely who is he turning
around for a few shots bar sit down to
200 HP now he gets to 300 off the spite
of red buff it's gonna be first but
brucey
now fame is looking for one he gets the
auto attack over it's a double kill
cruzi to start things off but BB Oh
who's he turns it baby an Uzi for
hundreds of 200 over the wall and
cleared out and that's gonna be the heal
from foe foe now see a coming in tries
to throw the cue down who's he gets a
triple kill to start the game you have
to be kidding me
hitting in case on my tie LPL sheet and
lost the pepper you guys an seer than I
am right now but it looks like y'all may
be right gonna be the bullet time BB
left a ride over LPL make go slow but
they're able to still turn and kharsa
behind the turret it's gonna have to
watch his teammate go down lantern there
to stop Ross will not take down po-po
and now nine five seven of the turn
thing in the tank that his team needs
the tank that his team deserves and
they're almost able to pick up another
kill the lp HP slowly in his car saw
that he's gonna have to get the bottom
stars and I can get in there hundred
twelve
feels the ferret and goes down about how
many members of LMS can make it out
Mako's once into sub factory I move down
to half looks like a favorite have the
out and yeah we'll have to retreat they
have to retreat you want to go in on
this week oh they make away easily go
Barcia gets the elder Drake this is huge
for the team lamp turned out as well
they're gonna go ahead and take time
aiko they lose one as they get
themselves to safety all bye
she is wall right there was actually
used this ball he drove in so a big
mechanical mistake from him but in so
flashing away then act against the towel
off his unhook it on the side if both
bows bolte his action unable to get to
save I'll send this and he's dead in the
game of puppy home can you wait there
Meiko flash head but back probably
should have had but it actually down she
may have not been able to make it back
into the ultimate level six in the
country
we see here with the tough lane we have
a mouse are coming with jonathan coming
so as puttin up a good fight here again
scoop a
oh man the Korean team looking for blood
on this one ambition goes that's that a
dog gym maybe first blood over the EU
makes a beat chump
tahm Kench 200 word officer take the to
him in this top lane with the shed bear
horse to flashed out of the way odds are
looking back to play the first blood for
North American top laner ji soo still
has thick skin look at the flying at the
ton the tongue comes out not quite
making this way just yet there's your
stun Oh shoo get out of it first blood
to beard fit hen look for an all-in
potentially good for whole pig minions
he's gotta go oh he's so low that's a
hydrant okay we get the arrow we gotta
have a dance-off I'm gonna you're gonna
pick to Gerrits you're not gonna dance
well almost all right fading for that
all right this baby's a little bit of
movement you see some oh here we go here
we go that's what you like to see that's
the money shot right there all sigh 101
baby this pledge remember if you get the
flash to you you cannot flash away when
you are silent the also stop the passive
right there he's like no no no sustain
for you see somebody play's me to play
for farmer you play before both these
guys
our name is Kirsten we're gonna go in
now able to find the sleepy trouble
bubble paddle star finds its way on to
lose you popped the heel Oh nearly down
barely walks away but I feel like
beggars kind of messing with him at ya
when he still has his ultimate he's just
gonna go in to finish come barriers all
and exhaust really nothing to worry
about exhaust down there for burping the
wave I just ticking that bacon evil aura
off yet- tail no mono and exhaust down a
barrier pump of that but faker faker
with the +6 to finish them off
yeah TC gets enraged there's the W yes
he has turret aggro but that turret shot
blocked right there look how close it it
just barely gives them enough time to
get off that last oil for the execute
it's time to make building your
champions easier
introducing the score eSports as new
builds calculator which allows you to
plug in items and runes to figure out
which build gives you the best stats the
new builds page also gathers information
on what the top players and your
favorite pros are building so you'll be
able to try them out yourself take
control of your champion and try out the
new feature on the score a sports is
builds website by clicking on the link
in the description below
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button